racing here tonight well a good friend
of mine does documentaries in India and
I heard this guy like Tom
not even the next thing is that
do you remember what your life was like
before you were on a series and what you
did every day to drum up work for
yourself okay I remember what life was
like and ya know it was great I was in
three theater companies and I was doing
from Shakespeare to classical to drama
I'm directing the stage fighting
everything else so very very busy and I
got to pick and choose what Rosa wanted
to do in Hollywood and then I didn't
have to go in for a day player at least
on the other because I was so busy on
stage and getting undersized of me so
that was good and then a role came along
for me on NYPD
he's out of the theater companies and
stay with that and then a couple of
months later I got the shield so what do
you think actors should know about the
business side even if they're just small
time and they're just getting their toe
in the water what should they know about
the business side back because so many
people don't want to go there but its
necessary three things you got to know
question why I was giving this business
urgent flows to save you money whenever
you can always work on your craft you
know it is it is a set of muscles that
need to be near
there is the world
and last year it was really your dream
there's nothing that will stop me yeah
and that's what really helped me I mean
when work isn't flowing I know that I'll
get myself in an acting job and if I'm
really working hard i go to put away the
money so that I when it slows down and
still okay I'm not buying the goods
today so that I'm not suffering tomorrow
and it's been good vice all along but
even as a seizure act the same things
happening doing for players and doing
tours I've put in the money away so and
that's a hard thing to remember because
it isn't it in flow business right and
lastly you think you'll be on Twitter
one day I don't think I have the
capacity to get together it's addicting
is it it is yeah once you try it I guess
I'll never know the first tweet is free
I guess I'm ever know all right thank
you